savior you're muted
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled keep it real with native
protein ms
i'm xavier gutierrez of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by agilent
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
please address each question to a
specific speaker
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i now present today's speakers dr
christian klein
product manager of elsie qudoff and i am
cued off at agilent
technologies and dr david wong senior
application scientist of
lcms solution the msd division at
agilent technologies
for a complete biography on dr christian
klein and dr david wong
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr dr christian klein you may now begin
your presentation
hello i will welcome you today to uh
agilent's virtual mass spectacular uh
event
and the topic of the day is keep it real
with native ms
my name is chris klein i'm the ltq and
i'm qt of
product manager and uh together with
david wong our senior application
scientist
i will give today a brief overview or
introduction
into what can be done on agilent's
instrumentation
with nativems
so on the first outline of my talk i
um want to present the biopharma
solutions agilent can offer and then
followed in by a bit
in-depth analysis of what the 6545xt
advanced bio-altitude
actually can do for the detectable
offline molecules
second and vast part of this talk is
given by david
about the native lcms analysis of
microfollicles
followed then by the characterization of
antibody si rna conjugates by native ms
and then lasts the native protein
characterization using high mobility
so going into the first level of
biopharma
and where to actually native ms is
needed for and this is basically
for everything related
biopharmaceuticals biopharmaceuticals in
its easiest definition are any
pharmaceutical drug products
manufactured in or extracted from
or seems synthesized from biological
sources
this can include living cells for
example reprogrammed t
cells but also somatic or genome-like
gene therapy like crispr arc s9
looking at other aspects blood blood
components thrombin
white blood cells blood flowing fusions
are also part of biopharmaceuticals
and so are toxin and antitoxins by sins
of course
are a big group but the biggest level
are currently used for the manufacturing
of
drugs are recommended proteins and
antibodies
so example for those classes are insulin
and of course monoclonal
so when we talk about monoclonal
antibodies the first thing everybody
noticed of course
they are big they're just looking at the
molecular weight
compared to saying uh herceptin which is
a drug used against breast cancer
against lipitor which has a molecular
weight of 559
so making the difference of hundred
eighty five thousand dollars
fifty five uh dolphins is basically the
same
as comparing the two stories single
family residential
compared to the empire state building
and with that of course the analytical
challenges are also growing
exponentially
and far more diversity within the
structure
different conformation isomers are
possible and they all need to be
properly characterized
here comes action into account where we
are for integrated solutions
so shifting uh from a biopharma
development focus
which is less about an inner product but
more about an entire
integrated workflow and the elements
needed for success
so starting off from the sample
preparation uh over here we've shown uh
essay map
the separation which can be done over uh
carry electrophoresis
or chromatography the detection of
course on the 6545xt
data analysis let it be bioconfirm or
quant analysis
leading finally to the report so firstly
from the first step a researcher puts
hand on measuring the samples
based on the sample prep to the final
report agilent
will be there with services and
consulting with expertise
and also of course has the consumables
and free agents
to support the customers from h
so starting now with the separation on
here basically the 1290 infiniti 2 uhblc
is a standard form because it allows us
for more or less most of the
applications being the most universal
instrument let it be peptide mapping
which requires a very high level of back
pressure compared to uh intact protein
analysis
or maybe even glycolysis 1290 infinity 2
is able to do this
not to forget of course our 7100 carry
electrophoresis instrumentation
again an aspect of whatever is most
suitable to the aspect
azure is there to support workflow
and of course 2dlc is a very important
differentiator
because again looking into native
analysis in itself the first step
typically are happening
in very salt containing buffers which by
nature
are not comparable to mass spectrometry
but again
using now different technologies
orthogonal separation
or these sorting steps make it very easy
to separate
first the isoforms and then either
denatured or under ms compatible native
conditions
to the mousepad this all goes together
with various forms of columns which are
designed as previously mentioned for
intact proteins
subunit peptide mapping glycan profiling
accurate analysis
charge variant analysis as well as also
spent media analysis
and of course the complexity goes even
further if you're looking into all the
different details in here
again looking here at the whole section
of agilent biomolecule columns
for cqa analysis we basically cover
all of the areas which are broad
portfolio of different columns
based really on the individual needs of
the analysis
i want to step over now to the next
aspect which is the detection
this is the analytical cornerstone for
multiple biopharma workflows
as typically uh the mass spec
instrumentation itself
needs to deal with all the different
workflow requirements let it be a small
molecule
let it be something like a peptide a
glycan or let it be a whole intake
monoclonal antibody
the instrumentation needs to be able to
perform all of
the these important aspect of the 65 45
xt development was
that it's poor protein spectral
clarity requires a very low uh top
vacuum this goes down to the 10 to the e
minus 8 torr
the reason for that is that remaining
nitrogen in the flight tube
still leads to collision and this
collision lead to later arrival times of
the iron
leading therefore to a loss of
information between the different
glycophones like lysines
so maintaining an as clear spectra as
possible is fundamental
for the analysis of monoclonal antibody
i will go a bit later more about a one
click optimization for large molecule
detection using a swarm altitude
most instruments are not necessarily
tuned for monoclonal antibodies
they are done for yielding and
resolution specs sensitivity
specification
but doing an application tune on that if
us and i'll show more example later to
this
large opportunities to optimize the
instrument performance
for those molecules
and then of course we have in the native
arena also very large molecule complexes
which requires a variable mass range up
to 30 000
m over z again some examples later to
come
with it all it comes to protein
performance verification and install
and the quick start protein method again
agilent
keeps the users from a to z and enables
them with a familiarization
as fast as possible to get the results
they require
another aspect of it is the ease of
maintenance every time an instrument
needs to get
vented for any kind of cleaning
procedures valuable time is lost
and one of the most aspects which
requires cleaning
again for native ms is the capillary
so on this we specifically developed the
vent free capillary removal
which allows us to remove the capillary
clean it
and immediately afterwards that be
operatable again without any downtime
loss
as mentioned before the large molecule
swarm altitude
uh is an extremely important and
powerful tool
to really move the needle further we see
here on the same instrument the same
sample
run once in blue uh with a large
molecule small altitude
and in red with our standard mass a
small altitude
not much difference of course in the
resolution of the glycophones
but we can see more than 4x increase
signal
and this is only at about 3000 democracy
the impact of the large molecule tune
evolves further and further higher the m
over z range
so this is an example really of smart
designing of the instrumentation
which allows us to be application based
and on the needs of the different
application
tune the instrument accordingly
our next example is shown here for the
monoclonal antibody
again this is now just shown under
denaturating conditions
to prove the statement which we made
about the separation of glycogens
what we call internally a kind of a peak
to hump ratio which is
in the raw spectra the abundance between
the glycoform
and the non-resolved part of here the
low vacuum
um of our 6545 xds
allows us here to really separate well
beyond
what's typically seen in raw mass spec
mass spectra this is a typical example
here
of just the 0.5 microgram of the nest
monoclonal antibody
a very short um chromatography of our
plrp at 1 000 column
and the impact on here is shown really
very well separate
it's an effect of this great separation
we of course also
maintain mass accuracy and again
the identification of um positive
translational modification
like here the loss of anastasia glucose
so why i'm showing those denaturating
conditions because
later on david will show you native uh
examples which
are extremely close in the resolving of
the glycoform
and the mass accuracy under those uh
well standard
denaturating conditions but again this
is important to understand where the
baseline is
and once the baseline is established to
move beyond this
and david will show the example for this
late
so one of the last things i want to show
off because there's always
the gold standard how does an instrument
be form actually with uh grover l
uh glory l is an 802 uh kilo dollar
4 timer a non-covalent complex
and it's principal the gold standard
because it comes up as
the the 14 mer at around 11 to 13 000
m over z and once inducing fragmentation
the 13 more comes even higher this
standard is readily available and it can
be used there for determine how is the
overall instrument performance
for those contacts so um what has been
done here was
to uh use nanoflow at 200 liters per
minute
very very low and source conditions with
low triggers flow and uh in order to
induce a later
on fragmentation uh
sf6 was used so
looking here at the mass spectra exactly
as i said before we see
very well resolved with very good
intensities and
signal to noise those are in this case
non-smooth spectra
and uh shown really how well those
different
charge states are resolved and actually
are moving
exactly as previous said up to uh
13 000 ammo so the next step
was then to uh induce the the
fragmentation
and what we can see here now and this is
uh done with an rnd prototype smoothing
functionality
fragments of on the 13mr of royale
very well again resolved to nearly the
baseline
so again this was just the proof of
concept yes on our 45 xt without any
kind of modification
or self-made changes to the optics
on the commercial available system we
can generate
data of quality which gives us really
the um basis of now being confident
to move native ms to the next level and
rather doing this with nanoflow
david wong and others develop methods to
do this with standard flow
and he will comment more over now the
next um
part of this talks over it so with this
i want to
thank you for your attention and really
want to give the floor to david now
for his part thank you
thanks chris hi everyone thanks again
to this ageless biospectacular virtual
event
my name is david wong and i'm an
application scientist at agilent
focusing on the biopharma application
development
in the second half of the presentation i
would like to talk about how agilent is
focused
on writing the automated native protein
analysis workflow
using the regular lc flow condition
media protein analysis by massback has a
broad range of
applications this analytical technique
can be used for porting
higher order structural property when it
combined with the eye mobility
management
it can also be used to analyze the
non-covalent
protein protein interactions protein
complexes
protein aggregation analysis and
bio-therapeutic samples such as
antibody or antibody drug conjugate
analysis
however the native ms analysis is still
facing tremendous analytical challenges
without organic solvent and acid to
enhance the sample
dissolvation and ionization native ms
analysis of protein sample
a neutral ph condition tend to have a
fewer charges per molecule
and much lower abundances in mass spec
signal
at higher mov range
so to overcome these challenges many
sample prep and analytical
technique has been developed such as the
sample cleanup
and the use of a method friendly vortex
buffer
also many people prefer to use the non
nano electrospray ionization approach
in the native protein analysis as they
can
increase the ms sensitivity however
this has it has been commonly been
observed that
the neutral equal protein sample tends
to
aggregate easily under the unstable
nanoflow rate conditions
and cause the nanospray emitter to clog
therefore we introduce here a highly
sensitive
protein native protein analysis workflow
using the regular lc
flow conditions no dedicated nano lc
system is needed
for this type of analysis
the workflow utilize the agilent's vents
biome size exclusion column
and the top 90 infinity 2 lc system
together with the 6545 xt2 top
and followed by the data analysis in
mass hunger for
core and file confirm software with the
maximum entropy for
protein deconvolution
this is the typical lc condition for
native protein analysis
to perform native ms analysis is
quick crucial to preserve the protein
sample
at the neutral ph and molecular equal
solutions such as ammonium entity
therefore
sample desorting and buffer change are
usually needed prior to the ms
analysis once the samples are dissolved
the agilent's advanced bio scc column
can be used
for further sample separation running at
the iso credit
mode with a full way at 0.2 million
minutes
the runtime is usually under 5 minutes
for the detailed information on the
system setup
please refer to our network
in order to validate whether we can
detect the native protein
under the standard lc flow condition we
first analyze the myoprotein sample
in myoglobin heme is non-covalently
attached
to the globin through the hydrogen bonds
and hydrophobic interactions
the hem is attached to the globin the
protein is referred to as the
horomyoglobin which is in that is a
native conformation
as shown in the top figure goblin is
denatured
in the organic acid solvent
and under hash ms source condition most
of the
native coral myoglobin was denatured
into the april myoglobin and gene
our optimized native ms analysis of
migration
clearly demonstrated the native
combination of
migration was it retained as shown in
the bottom figure
only a trace amount of dissociation
could be detected
we then want to see how ionic strings of
the scc
column mobile phase effect the protein
native non-covalent complex
this slide demonstrate the native ms
analysis of power quality hydrogenate
under two mobile phase conditions
even though both mobile phase were
neutral ph
protein dissociation uh product the
dimer or other
monomer well so when ammonium forming
was a substitute for ammonium acid in
the mobile phase
also the charged state envelope
of the intake native adh
at the 50 mil more ammonium forming
was shipped to the lower mmorpg range
compared to that in that 100 millimolar
ammonium acetate
therefore we believe that a 100
millimolar ammonium acetate solution at
ph
7 offers better structural protection
for protein complexes during the native
ms analysis
now let's look at how the native ms
analysis behaves on the monoclonal in
the body
the top mass spectrum represents a lcms
analysis of an antibody standard beneath
antibody using the regular
organic and acid solvent as a mobile
phase
we call this as a denaturing conditions
as you can see
the charged state distribution of the
nature
of this and the body over the mass range
of ammo was
200 2000 to 5000
and charges from 30 to 75
when we apply uh the same high-flow
scclc method
for the native uh antibody and
ms analysis so we got a charge envelope
in the
range of mmoc 5000 to ten thousand
as shown in the msd convoluted spectrum
on the right size so we obtain a very
narrow peak
and excellent mass accuracy for all the
major geico phone
we also achieve very good agreement
with the data from the intact missed
anal body analysis
under both ms condition
similarly uh the native ms analysis of
the about
biopsy already dropped the perception
and its antibody dot conjugate the tdm1
example must perform and compare
the top panel is the native ms
analysis of the intact perception
showing
a nice distribution charge envelope
from 5000 to 10 000
with the charges stay between 15 to 28.
the most prominent charges they was at
24
which indicating that uh intact
perception
was in is the native or the florida
conformation
also we achieve a very uh impressive
low ppm mass accuracy and excellence
resolution for all the type of form
of the herceptin under the native lcms
condition
the bottom panel shows that the native
law and the convoluted ms spectrum of
the pdm1
the average dog value calculated using
the welcome form
dot calculator was a 3.5
which is consistent with the dot value
of the intake adc
reported by genentech now we want to see
if the native ms analysis method also
work
on the non-covalent protein complexes
we use another protein standard called
the beta electrocyties which is the
tetramer
under this native conformation
the molecular weight of each monomer is
about 116 kilo dalton
under the denaturing lcms condition
only the monomer and also a small
amount of thymol form can be detected
the bottom panel shows that the native
beta glycosidase detriment with the
charge state distribution
ranging from m over z 8
500 to 15 000 days darker
and the the commodity intact mass of
this
tetramorph protein is about 465
kilograms
we don't want to see how far out we can
detect the protein complexes
using uh this native ms analysis
we analyzed several of the classic
protein
complexes standard such as the pyruvate
kinase
which is a tetramer glutamate
dehydrogenase and hexamer
and greater beta glactocide is
attachable
by looking at the charge state
distribution
of these complexes we can get a low
lower charge state at much higher mov
value
utilizing our large molecules from
autotune
to dramatically improve the ion
transmission
of very large protein molecules we can
easily
detect the protein complexes up to
almost
half million thousand so this
these are the excellent example of
maintaining
structural integrity of the intake
protein
complexes
now i would like to turn our attention
to the native ms analysis of
antibody rna conjugate
small interferent rna with also called
si rnas on a promising type of rna
based psoriatic drug that
demonstrate the effectiveness on the
gene silencing
through rna interference technology
using antibody as a delivered vehicle
antibody rna conjugate enable the
delivery of
si rna to the targeted cell surface
however characterization of such intake
and the antibody rna conjugate using the
traditional
lcms method present about and
bioanalytical challenges due to the
weaker bounding between the silence and
modified inner body molecule
therefore we have developed a normal
lcms method
for the characterization of antibody and
sir in a conjugate
under their native condition
antibody rna conjugate were produced by
size
specific conjugation between the free
system
residues of the human igg antibody
and rna molecule the chemical synthesis
involved in partial reduction of the
inner body
and followed by the conjunction with the
activated rna molecule
the unreactive free spiral group of the
the body but then modify uh with the
chemical reagents
not in label here as the cap
unreacted in the body uh and also rna
the dot one molecule which is the
conjugate with
one oligo molecule or the dot 2
with the two oligo molecule of antibody
and on the fbi and a molecule would then
separate it
by the ion and change chromatography
the purified are one sample was then
used for the mass back analysis
under the measuring and the native
condition
again here's the typical lc lc-ms
workflow for the protein analysis
under the traditional lc condition on
the left side
of that table organic solvent and acid
are usually used in protein
sample denatured
in order to carefully capitalize the
antibody and rna conjugate native lcms
analysis is a must to preserve that
integrity
and also the native confirmation of the
molecule
so in this study we use the longer
advanced bio
sec column which is the 300
millimeter and also isocratic flow at
0.3 mil per minute of the 100 millimolar
ammonium acetate
as a solvent for the better separation
of the target r-1 molecule and
other impurities
this is the lcms analysis of the intact
unconjugated and the causeway antibody
control
under the dimension conditions the porp
column
was used so you can see a typical charge
state distribution of the denaturing
antibody in the mass range of m over z
2000 to 5 000
so as this was the fully the
cost related antibody sample so only one
major protein was detected
we also utilized the reverse phase lcms
analytical approach
to analyze the mr the antibody rna
conjugate
under the denaturing conditions the top
the top panel shows the lcms profile of
the glycosylated
intake and the body iron conjugate the
dot one sample
the middle window is the extracted iron
chromatogram
of the chromatography separated peaks
over the retention time
of 3.4 to 4.3 minutes
um so so showing that several of the
charge state distribution
over the mass range of ammo was 1000 to
4 000
so this is indicating that many
biomolecules
exist in the sample
so therefore we perform the ms data
deconvolution and
mass matching to the protein of
other oligonucleotide sequence on each
of the four
lce peaks over this retention computer
to obtain as much detail information as
possible
the msd convolution mass range was set
from 20 kilo thousand to 160 2000
for the raw ms data of all four lcps
this board mass range should cover small
proteins such as the antibody light
chains
all the way up to the antibody on a
conjugate
after careful calculations so many
degraded and reduced antibody or the
antibody or only bone conjugate form
or identify and label in that figure
these are the results for the lcps one
and two the structural assignment
are based on the mass matching and
hypothesis of the
conjugation reactions further
investigation is needed to identify
the actual conjugation side of this
molecule
and these are the peak 2 and 4 results
as you can see they are modified
antibody light chains modified antibody
heavy chains
with either the the cap or the
rna molecule half of the half of the
conjugate
or the conjugate without
one line change or two light chains
only a trace amount of the intact
anabolic rna conjugate
could be detected so this results
indicate that
most of the antibody rna conjugate were
dissociated
under the measuring lcms conditions
as the conjugation reaction uh was very
likely happened
at the disulfide bound between the light
change and heavy chains
so it broke that strong disulfide bond
linkage
and turned them into a weak
electrostatic
interaction so therefore it's very
difficult
to detect the intact conjugate under the
traditional lc
ms condition using organic or acid
solvent
so that that makes the native lcms
analysis an ideal analytical tool
for characterizing the intake
non-covalent of the acid lay bio
in the body rna conjugate so here is the
lc
ms profile of the intake unconjugated
and the glycosylated antibody control
under the native conditions so the
longer
the long scc column was used here
as we demonstrate earlier the typical
charge
state distribution of the antibody
under the native lcms condition is in
the match range of
mozi 5000 to 10 000.
again our pure top source condition
will optimize and excellence the quality
of the native ms
spectra with less than 5 ppm
in match arrow was a 10.
the 6545 xt advanced by
lcq top system demonstrate excellent
sensitivity for
antibody rna quantity under the native
lc-ms conditions
approximately 5 micrograms of the
conjugate sample
were injected onto an advanced bio sec
long column
so we use the 12 minute iso credit flow
at the 0.3 mil per minute here
a longer chromatography run method was
developed to optimize the sample
separation
and to maximize the sensitivity of
detection
the top window shows that a native scc
column separated
intact the in glycosylated body rna
conjugate
so two major lcp with the mss charge
envelope ranging from uh the mmoz
5000 to 10 000 uh detect
that the common loaded spectrum revealed
that
there are two major forms of antibody
rna conjugate in each lc peaks
peak one contains the dark one with one
cap
and also that one with three cap
and this that the commercially become
already ms
spectrum of peak two so in here you can
see
anybody with two cap was the most
abundant
molecule and the dot one with one cap
was the carry over from the pit one
as i mentioned uh during the
introduction the
native protein analysis plays a key role
in the protein higher order structural
proteins
by the eye mobility mass spec
the agilent 6560i mobility q-top is
considered
as the coolest commercial available high
mobility system
because it can minimize the ion heating
effect
from the amazon system and therefore can
preserve the native protein structure
much better this is an
animation which illustrates the basic
operational
principle of the eye mobility within the
conventional chip to
design nitrogen is
used as the main buffer gas in the chip
tool
and the chip cell operates at the
pressures of photo
and the direct current uh electrophile
is used to drive the ion from the
trap funnel into the drip cell and then
into the rear funnel so
let's say we have two compounds
one has more dense ball shape and the
other is more open
kind of shape so when the iron gate
opens the [ __ ] molecule has fewer
gas collision
and arrive the detector faster why the
different shape molecule has more gas
collision
and come out later so therefore the
ball shape which is the native molecule
has a less drip time and a smaller
collision cause a section value
the iron heating effect from the
ethylene 6560
high mobility kill top lcd ms system
hysteresis has been minimized which is
critical
for maintaining the native protein
conformations
here we are showing the im analysis of
cyber bond c
uh using various uh mass back source
condition
the energy so by changing the top
voltage
we can change the protein conformation
from its native stage
which is the s1 stage
to various degree of the major stage
s2 to s5
by comparison with the other ion systems
the agilent supreme ion system require a
much lower energy
uh which minimize the iron heating
effect
that can cause the denaturation of the
protein molecules
so these are the i am q-top analysis of
an antibody
under the denaturing and the native lc
ms conditions again under the normal
lcms
condition with the higher
organic solvent or the acid
in the buffer the native protein
conformation
will be destroyed and let's demonstrate
it
here under the native condition
uh we use the 100 millimolar ammonium
acetate on ps7
the antibody is less has less charges
and it's the charges emerald shift to a
higher mmoc
so um so we also use eye mobility
to analysis to look at other
biotherapeutics so the lutecy map
is the monoclonal antibody can treat
many disease
as the patterns covering this originator
product it's called also called
innovator
was expired many years ago so
many bio pharma company
has produced the nutrition at the
biosimilar
order by the non-originator of biologics
clause um so in this study you use the
eye mobility cube
to compare the innovator and
and its biosimilar products
so even though the innovator and is the
biosimilar
uh have exactly the same protein
sequence
the biosimilar seems to have a slightly
larger glycan modification groups
because it depends on where the
different
expression holds so for example
the ccs at the 27 charge
stage molecule was
the larger for the bio similar products
which is highlighted in green and also
in the below the table here
you can see the comparison between the
innovator
and the bio molecule biosimilar
so therefore the eye mobility mass spec
can provide
not only the size but also the molecular
molecular structural information on the
biosimilar
in the biosimilar studies
high mobility can also be used to study
the protein complexes
or the protein protein interaction under
the native conditions
in this study of 330 killed out in
protein complexes
the the hexamer of bovine glutamate
dehydrogenase
was successfully analyzed under the
native condition
the charge state envelope of the gdh is
shown in the
mass range uh movie of 8000
to 10 000.
so we have also successfully determined
that
ccs value of the 40 uh
charge states of the gdh which is almost
twelve thousand square m tension
now i would like to share some of my key
learning
with you on how to optimize the ms data
quality
uh and results during the native lcms
analysis the first area is the sample
prep
so i normally use the sample buffer
with 50 to 100 millimolar
ammonium acid at ps7
to dissolve uh and dilute sample
and also the offline dissolving uh
before the
lcms analysis is a must so i normally
use uh
the biore files in cartridge for the
desalting
for the lcms data acquisitions so i
would recommend
always analyze the threshold prepare
sample
this is especially critical for antibody
samples
and use the online scc either the guard
column or the long column
for further sample separation of the
sorting
so run lc in the isocratic mode with 100
millimolar ammonium acetate as a solvent
and for small proteins use the lower
dry gas or the sheet gas temperature
around 150 celsius degree
and also we prefer to uh perform the
large molecules for model 2 and
before the data acquisitions
so in conclusion we have developed a
complete and
efficient workflow solution for native
protein analysis
by running the large molecule
thrombotomy
we can improve the detection sensitivity
over the extended mass range for the
native intake protein compresses
we have also optimized the native lcms
condition for the intel
ender body rna conjugate analysis
last but not least utilizing our native
protein sample prep
method along with the adjurance high
mobility kill top system
we can preserve the native protein
structure
for their accurate ccs determination
for many biopharma related analysis we
have created
an agilent's biopharma web page where
you can find
all kinds of useful information such as
many uh training
video as well as the on demand
webinars so hope this information can
help you
to improve your productivity and to
obtain better
results with this i want to thank you
for your time
and attention
thank you dr christian klein and dr
david wong for your informative
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll get to your question now let's
get started
the first question is going to be for
christian
can you explain how you can get this
large increase for monoclonal antibodies
by just tuning
sure so the reason for that is that
for most applications small molecules
are used
and for that the mass resolution so the
distinction between other different
isotopes
is extremely important for large
molecules like monoclonal antibodies we
don't have any more
the isotopic resolution and with that we
actually are not dependent on the
classic small molecule tube
so what we did instead was to use a tune
which was solely based on the
transmission of ions
to get us the best sensitivity and by
that also in several elements in the ion
optics
do show the best transmission for large
molecules
and so this is all the combination of a
tune
and the addressing the optical
lenses particularly we were able to get
a 4 to 5 x
sensitivity increase
thank you uh for the next question we
have uh for david it's going to be
how much proteins do you normally need
for the native ms analysis
um i normally use about um
like some microgram to about 10
microgram protein depends on the protein
sample
however i really i haven't really tried
to push the detection
limit uh the sensitivity on the native
ms
analysis but i i guess it should be
around a low
uh nanogram level
and what is the typical im resolution
for the 6560 i am cued off
uh the typical im resolution for the
6560 qtop
is about 50 but uh we we have the
quality multiplexing technique with that
technique we can push the im resolution
can go up to about 150
okay and looks like we have this last
question here
in the ion mobility part you said that
the drift times are much smaller
compared to the native one
can you please explain this
yes so when proteins under the measuring
condition that structure usually would
turn from the
ball ship into the loose open structure
which can have more charges onto the
molecule
the sample as i showed earlier for the
igg2
we are looking at the different charge
envelope so
on the denaturing igg2 has a charge
angle of about
45 to 70 and the native
charge envelope is about 20 to 35
for the same charge iron usually the
duke time would be much larger
for the denaturing molecule
well thank you both for your answers do
you have any final comments for our
audience
well thank you very much for the
attention of the seminar and
i really hope that the data that david
showed gives you real confidence about
that a robust native mass spec analysis
is actually possible
and uh with all the development we have
done on the
turf with the um all workflow
consumables and reagents we supply from
agilent
we are really hoping uh to be a partner
with you for
your research and thanks again for
joining the seminar thank you
well dr klein and dr vaughn thank you so
much for your time today and
your important research before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june of 2021
until next time goodbye